he is the skipper of the Oakland
Athletics Bob Melvin here and the Rich
Eisen show how are you Bob
I'm good so were you the one who called
security on us that night you know I
just news to me I had no idea about this
usually I hear about things like that
but didn't get to me so you shouldn't
you probably weren't causing that much
commotion okay good good because we
thought that we were a little loud we
heard the A's were in the in the hotel
and that they were complaining so
unfortunate that puts a little takes a
little wind out of our sails we were
trying to take a little bit of credit
here for your success well I you know
what every little bit helps so I'll give
you some credit so let's thank you
that's always looking for so six
consecutive wins here a bob just in the
short term and and then just a an
incredible I guess coming together team
wise and just every phase of the game to
what to do you owe what is happening
this season well I'll tell you we felt
like we had a good group coming into
spring training last year you know we
played well the last couple months of
the season some of our high profile
prospects came up and had some success
which you know lends to some confidence
going into the season and then you know
just at one point everything came
together certainly our bullpen is a big
part of it you know Lou Trevino coming
up and doing what he's done obviously
Blake trying in at the back end of the
bullpen you know and then Adam some
pieces along the way whether it's from
development and or guys like jeurys
Familia you know just everything seems
to be coming together and I think the
fact that everybody is part of it you
know all 25 guys really guys in the
minor leagues like Frankie Montes and
Daniel mengdan and and you know it's
more than 25 so that can be a powerful
thing when everybody feels like they're
part of it most terms of powerful things
to a player who gained a little bit of
national spotlight for you Bob because
of what was going on with his mom as
steve Piscotty who came to the team last
year from st. Louis because his mom was
stricken with ALS and he wanted to be
around
her and she passed away he singles when
he comes back when he comes back and in
the homers when he's back after grieving
I mean what has it been like to be
around him yeah that's a pretty surreal
story and you know guy that they grew up
in the Bay Area was an Oakland A's and
as a kid to be able to come back here
and then spend what was a difficult few
months with his mom and be there every
day I know was really important to him
and you know now he's just kind of
settling back into his game here the
last couple of months which is which is
a pretty good brand of baseball that he
plays and you know I think he'll tell
you he's got quite the angel on his
shoulder right now too so you know there
are a lot of good stories that that
pertain to what's going on with right
right now but I don't know that it won't
any better than Stephen Piscotty well
what did Joe what did the team glean
from him just watching him and watching
him work well what was going on in his
personal life was oh boy yeah they knew
the story before I even got here and
then you know obviously being a part of
it with the clubhouse every day and he's
you know he's become a big personality
with us too and you know the home run I
think that he hit when he came back from
his mom's funeral in Boston and his
first at-bat just really electrified our
dugout and you know really you know kind
of put this whole process that he's had
to go through kind of at a different
level and like I said now he's just
settled in the plane like baseball like
he plays and you know he's a big part of
the success Bob Melvin athletics manager
here on the Rich Eisen show where does
Chris Davis rank amongst homerun hitters
that you've been around playing man I
you know based on the fact that he's on
his way to hitting 40 home runs for the
third year in a row in Oakland and you
know guys like Canseco McGwire if they
have not done that here art ballparks
difficult to hit home runs and
especially at night and for him to do it
in the consistent fashion he has since
he's been here puts him right at the top
with anybody I've ever had and so what
what does he mean for this lineup he's
the force in the middle of it that you
know is consistently there and you know
we have some nice parts around it
certainly Jed Lowery had a terrific
first half made the all-star teams the
first time in his
career you know in the three hole and
and you really kind of between the two
of those guys carried us early on and
now everybody's kind of filling in you
know up and down the lineup were you
know we feel like we're a deep line but
have a chance to score every inning so
but Chris is kind of that mainstay in
the middle it's always one swing away
from three runs well I mean the I guess
a sense of a lot of folks outside
looking in Bob is that you're you're
playing with not a full deck compared to
the rest of big market teams because of
the economics of of baseball and the
athletic situation in general would you
agree with that assessment well you know
I mean it's documented I think we're
last in payroll going into season I know
we sit right now we've we've added a few
guys but typically that doesn't happen
very often but we do also have some some
really good young players that really
aren't making any money yet you know as
far as baseball is concerned I mean
relative to the to the real world
obviously but so I think you know that
allows us to have some success that
maybe did people didn't see early on but
I don't think it's a surprise to us
anymore we're you know we're just trying
to go out there and play the best we can
and on a particular day and try to win
and based on the fact that we've had a
nice little run there's some confidence
that goes along with it if baseball
passed a rule saying that infielders had
to have at least one foot on the dirt to
try and I guess released the grip of
shifting would you agree with that Bob I
don't I mean it's yeah I'm a bit of a
baseball traditionalist but this isn't
the first time we've seen shifts I mean
I grew up in in the Bay Area here when
Willing Maccabi was getting shifted way
back when and Ted Williams and you know
it's it's you know there's certain
things I might look to change but that I
don't know that that's one of them
because what you're doing is you're
trying to put your guys in the best spot
to create outs and you know there's
there's different ways to to try to
combat that hits ball the other way
maybe bunt to try to get the shift moved
over for you so that that's one that I
probably wouldn't before but in this day
and age now I mean will when you
pointing out about Ted and Willie
McCovey there was really no such thing
as exit speed
and all the other aspects of analytics
is put into play here Bob it just seems
that half the game you're either
watching a walk a strikeout or a homerun
and and they're there is a concern about
that at least in terms of watch ability
rekt but I don't think that you know
Walker or a strikeout or a home run
plays necessarily into the shifts I mean
I think it's almost now where you're
seeing four outfielders you know with
the with the infielder out in the
outfield almost in it I think it comes a
day where maybe there is a fourth
outfielder
literally and and you know not as many
infielders but you know it is what it is
right now and they're like I said
there's ways to combat it and and you
know it's it's probably swings back the
other way if guys look to do that what
about the advent bob of starting closers
that we're beginning to see a little bit
more in baseball what do you think of
that advent that worse I think that's
based on the personnel you have and you
know if if you have you know you look at
the run Tampa's pretty creative group
and and they're looking at the amount of
runs that are given up in the first
inning and that typically is the time
that you can get to a starter is a
little bit more vulnerable early on and
now you're bringing in a reliever that's
used to pitching one inning if you have
you're looking at Houston Astros I don't
think they really need to do that they
have five starters that go out there and
have a chance you know to go deep in the
games every time I think it's more the
personnel that they have and trying to
maximize what they can do over there so
you know it's not something I think we
need to do right now but but I think
they're smart and in trying to work it
that way based on their personnel well
Bob a couple more minutes left with you
here you just swept the Tigers your one
six Inori just came from Detroit where
you broke in to the big leagues in in
the mid-80s do you have any Sparky
Anderson in you anybody that you have
from your playing days that you you put
into your managing where again you've
one manager of the year in both leagues
only one of seven guys to ever do such a
thing
well yeah I try to take a little bit of
you know everybody I've been around as
far as managers go and players as well I
came up in that system and when you come
up in a system make it to the big
leagues it's really like kind of a
university you know your freshman and
your sophomore you finally make it to
varsity I came up behind guys like Kirk
Gibson and Alan Trammell and Jack
Morrison and Lance Parrish and Lou
Whitaker and got to watch them firsthand
and see how they played the game so
they're very impactful my in my career
Kirk Gibson was just here announcing
he's been a good friend of mine and took
care of me as a rookie but I try to take
little bits and pieces of every team
I've been on and every manager I've
played for good and bad so but the
Tigers are definitely a team that didn't
probably you know resonates as much as
any based on the fact I came up with
who's the best player you ever played
with that's a tough question
played with man there are a lot of
really good ones I you know how can you
go wrong with Cal Ripken and and what he
did in Baltimore you know maybe maybe
not the you know the streak and and what
he brought to the table every single day
he took batting practice every day took
infield every day and he played in every
inning every game that's pretty good one
to start with yeah that's a that's an
awesome one to start with okay so do you
talk to your team about what's
developing I mean how do you how do you
address the the success that you've had
so far to maintain it how do you do that
with your team Bobby you know what I try
to stay pretty consistent and when we
have advance meetings you know every to
start every series I kind of add a
little something there's certain times
during the year when then maybe you need
to address some things there haven't
been that many this year so I just try
to you know stay consistent and you know
what happened the series before and and
you know kind of what we need to do in
this series and you know our clubhouse
for a mostly younger group of guys is
pretty well policed and we have some
veteran guys in there that know how to
run a clubhouse so you just kind of take
it series this series and when you think
you need to be impactful with what you
need to say and
you've got right across the street from
you there in that Stadium a dynastic
team in the NBA if you had in
relationship with the Warriors at all
Bob anybody any I guess other than
draymond Green coming in one of your
games during the finals a couple years
ago yeah we were aware of that no I you
know what I grew up you're watching the
Warriors since I was a young kid and
going to those games and my godfather
was actually dick deliever who was the
trainer for the Warriors for a long long
time back in the championship 75 so I
was able to become a fan early on and
and certainly now as well I know Steve a
little bit Steve Kerr lives up you know
has lived up the street from me for a
while since he's been here too and you
know to be able to kind of watch what
they're doing and in you know next door
and and you know kind of try to take
some of that vibe that that they have in
the championships that they have it's
it's an it's a nice neighbor to have put
it that way
so you knew draymond Green was in the
house that night we did we knew he was
coming that night I kind of made a joke
and said if he wants to hang up my
office he's more than more than happy
but I think probably Suites a little
better place to yes to be with Marshawn
Lynch to if I'm not mistaken that's what
I understand yeah he went I went to Cal
and so you know the lynch factor and the
barrier factor here there's a lot of
that so we'll start talking about Melvin
quakes very soon let's start talking
hey look it's great to see what's
happening right there it's been a lot of
fun to watch and good luck down the line
we'll chat again soon hopefully thank
you I appreciate you bet that's Bob
Melvin of the Oakland Athletics hey he
going back to the Rick Barry years Barn
a cup of sugar from Steve Kerr up the
street the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience